i get to see how they're wired i get to
see what makes them tick i get to see
what they're motivated by so now
when it comes time to get great you know
great effort out of them i know what
moves the needle for them personally
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
so on this episode uh we're talking to
dan we're asking about them
asking about the episode we talked about
we broke down the co-working space
and we and we found like an interesting
opportunity uh
a founder started and sold the company
in that space and he still said he would
start another company in that space and
thinks it could be huge which is a good
sign we talked about
this weird business called ice barrels
and then we talked about
the nike for recovery the nike of
recovery uh which is a really
interesting company
great story and we talked about adam
newman the founder of wework and how
he's got this like crazy
hypnotic personality and i love learning
about
that i actually think it's like
something that you need if you're gonna
ever
lead anyone and then i shared a steve
jobs story i heard
that may or may not be true i have no
idea
but it could be true it could be true
that's all i will guarantee
all right that's the episode um by the
way if there's like a follow button on
your spotify
do me a favor click that because we're
trying to grow the podcast and then
click the subscribe button on itunes
thank you it literally makes us like you
only need like a handful of people in
order to like go
up in the ratings and it's because of
that i think so click it
what's up what's going on cool shirt
thank you me or dan dan got
uh dan got a harvard shirt also so he's
part of the crew now
oh there you go dan you look nice
but i actually dan did you go to harvard
i could see that yeah he looks like a
harvard man
i didn't go to harvard but i have been
to the bookstore oh all right same
same same um what's going on anything
new
uh yeah lots of new stuff but let's jump
in we have a bunch of topics today so
we'll uh
we'll spare people to small talk um
all right i think they'd like that but
that's fine i'm down let's get down to
business uh where do you want to go
first
um you have something that you did a
bunch of research on i want to go
go to that first was it the co-working
spaces you were going into what are you
looking at
yeah so oh by the way i see of ice
barrel here interesting
yes um i'm happy to discuss that um ice
um
co-working so on our trip ben made a
suggestion
he i i was one of us was teasing like we
should do this we should do this we
should do this
him or you or me one of us but he he was
kind of nailing down the point
mentioned co-working yeah and i was like
that's kind of cool i think his quote
was
he's like but here's my big idea for the
podcast
uh take the mfm take my first million
and uh
and create like a network of co-working
spaces that already exist just license
the name
out and offer the promotion to your
members to be
to be able to access them that was his
idea yeah yes and
i started thinking about that and i've
always i wanted to get a little bit more
into real estate
and i thought it was cool and i just
basically put the bat signal out there
and i tweeted out who is an expert in
co-working i want to learn and what i
love to do for this pod i did this with
this vending machine
all i do is i get someone on the phone
and i don't want to bring them on the
podcast because they mean they're boring
or they're not good
at this type of thing right but i
basically just want to ask them tons of
questions and that's what i did and i
took notes
and so i found a guy named preston uh i
actually don't know how to pronounce his
last name i know i never know
how to pezic p-e-s-e-k so his twitter
handle is preston pezik p-e-s-e-k
and he had this company called spacious
which he sold
for um he sold the wework and i imagine
he sold it for a lot of money because
when i called him it was like noon east
coast time and he was just going for a
bike ride his butt so it doesn't work
anymore
yes well it looked like he was in like a
nice area of town in new york and he
wasn't working so i imagine it was a
good deal
but have you heard of uh spacious by any
chance what was it
okay does it still exist or they shut it
down they shut it down but it was crazy
interesting so the way so so we're going
to talk about co-working right now and
we're going to talk about where the
opportunities are
and where this guy where this guy thinks
there's opportunities and he has an
interesting perspective
he wouldn't tell me the revenue but i
bet i would imagine it was north of
eight figures a year in revenue
but spacious what it did originally was
they would find
restaurants that were only open at night
or had most of their business from six
to you know dinner time and they would
do a co-working thing where they you
would pay a little bit of money
29 i believe and you would get access to
to use this restaurant as a co-working
uh place
so i'd heard of this before that there
are restaurants that basically have
prime locations nice interiors and
they're only going to be used during
meal times and so the kind of pre-dinner
service
which is like your work day they were
turning into this i i remember thinking
oh that's cool and i never heard about
it again
so i sort of assumed it didn't work but
what you're saying is it started to kind
of work and they got acquired
no so what he was saying that it worked
wonderfully but wework made him an offer
so good he's like i can't refuse this
um i don't know if this guy i met he
worked at a hedge fund before but maybe
like you know he he didn't come from a
rich background and it was a big deal so
i don't blame them
but basically it started by doing
restaurants eventually it did retail
so what that means is um you have uh
uh some type of like ground level real
estate
and they would make a deal with the
retail uh
so retail uh real estate so not
necessarily like it's not like a
lululemon store it's like
a store that's typically used for
lululemon they would make deals with
them for as short as 30 days but
it could be as long as six to 12 months
where they would lease the place
and then they would charge people 29 and
you would try to get people to come in
it's called a a hot seat basically so
like a pop-up
yeah well you know what that is hot
desking yeah so basically you don't have
you don't have an assigned seat you come
in and it's sort of like
first come first serve type of thing for
the day so if i told you about this and
you didn't know anything about the
business i imagine you'd be skeptical
and think like this doesn't this
probably can't work that well right
i'd be like yeah it's hard right uh you
know it's cool to have the airbnb for
for
for for co-working or for your for work
and uh
i've heard of a lot of people try this
people are trying this with your home
you could take part of your home and
turn it into a
like a cafe for people uh to come and
sit and have wi-fi
and um i just felt like i never heard
from any of these companies ever again i
heard the idea and then likes
crickets for the next two years so
according to preston who
started and exited the company he uh he
may not start this because like i don't
know if i want to start another company
but he goes
i would love to invest in this space
which is always a great sign if someone
has started and sold something and still
wants to go back and do it he goes
it crushed it and i think that someone
could still crush it he goes
it's just like a hotel uh four seasons
can exist and also like um
motel 6. a motel 6 like a lot of
different brands can exist in this space
but it's incredibly lucrative and it can
work wonderfully so for his spaces the
way it would work is
they would have at least 100 seats which
means 100
place 100 areas that someone could sit
so 100 seats
and then they would have check-ins but
they would aim to have 200 to 300 seats
in a good location the target was 15
check-ins
per month and if a location had that
29 that comes out to be around 90 000 a
month
and uh the profit margin on that could
be about 40 percent
right so one low and that and that
profit margin includes
the the person manning the location and
then
rent so quite lucrative and he was like
yeah we we could crush it
and he was like you could definitely
bootstrap this into a smaller location
but he goes i think that there's a lot
of space for this and if you're gonna do
it
raise as much money as you possibly can
and i think a person could build a
business that makes a hunt
or makes a billion dollars a year in
revenue so how is this different than
just
we work right like isn't this just i'll
explain so
the problem with wework basically it's
long so so
here i've tried to break this down into
a framework and so the reason why a lot
of co-working doesn't work
now we're talking about uh what's it
called hot desk hot desk is different
than
quote the traditional when you think of
traditional co-working you probably
think of like
a freelancer or a small business owner
who wants to
spend 300 a month to have a desk all the
time at a
at a wework so let's just call that the
traditional
we uh co-working and the way that that
worked is basically you sign an
agreement for 10 years for a lease and
then you go and do arbitrage where you
find all right if
i'm spending this much in my lease per
square foot i'm going to subdivide it
and i'm going to rent it
uh for a short term but there's here's
the issue
long-term liability meaning your 10-year
lease
with a short-term uh income stream a
short-term rental agreement and so the
people
may only stay for two three four months
because it's a month-to-month
lease that you're renting to your and he
goes he goes basically you just get
churn and it's just hard to keep up with
that and because things can change
like a pandemic where everyone works
from home yeah and
he's like that it just doesn't work and
so what we did was we took
short-term liability meaning a lot of
their places
can um kick them out at any time but
they had so many of them and it was
considered like a pop-up that it was
okay
and so it didn't matter if a place
closed for a little while because they
can just go somewhere nearby in that
building
um or in that area and so it worked out
really really well
okay i um i don't know if it's because i
didn't talk to this guy or what but i
still
feel a little bit like yeah you know
same [__] different toilet
um as far as like i'm not sure i'm not
sure i don't
i don't fully understand why this is
that much better than traditional
co-working and i think traditional
co-working is
you know kind of marginal marginally
good or maybe
i've just seen some disasters right
breather uh breather raised a ton of
money
and looked like they were the next
unicorn and i think so ended up selling
for three million dollars so
they sell to three million dollars for i
don't know like you know
i i have like an uncle who could have
bought breather right so so it didn't
have like a fantastic exit what wework
is also run into problems that i think
were not just the pandemic but
um this arbitrage model was sort of thin
so
i don't know i'm a little bit skeptical
but okay where do you see the
opportunities beyond that's okay
if you're skeptical to be honest i'm
skeptical too but i still think it's
cool
but i've got another angle here yeah so
co-working i asked him but co-working
sounds more interesting because i want
that lo
i want that like more uh i want that
recurring revenue and i don't want to
open up like loads of locations
how do i make that work he goes well the
best way that you can make that work is
you've got supply and you've got demand
and the the supply being um i'm probably
gonna
screw up my supply and demand so
actually let's just skip that part
uh but basically you have your consumers
so your people who want to come and rent
that place he was like
that's actually not that important
what's important is that you pick good
locations and you do the real estate
part well
but um what if you could figure that out
which is like
kind of straightforward but still a lot
of work you have to figure out how to
make your consumers incredibly sticky
and the only way that he could find that
can make it sticky is you have to have
shared interests so for example do you
know the wing
yeah yeah the female co-working space he
says that that's a great business and
the reason is is that there's likely not
gonna be the reason why you need to be
sticky is you need someone to be willing
to stay there for
over a year right and so he goes shared
interest is the best way and he goes how
do you come up with shared interest
you go to facebook groups you go to
meetup.com and you just find like
whatever is like people have like a fan
base so it could be like
uh women it could be different minority
groups
it could be fitness enthusiasts he's
like i think that there's a huge
opportunity for people in co-working as
long if you can make it sticky
so people working on similar types of
things they don't want to leave their
their office that's where you have a a
really good business whereas we work it
didn't really have that as much
right so maybe an mfn co-working
business could actually work but maybe
not yeah
maybe maybe you know one interesting
thing i don't know if you saw there's a
bank
that did uh co-working inside of it i
think chase bank or well it was awesome
i used to go there all the time
well which one was it uh capital
capital capital one or whatever the
capital one is
it the capital one chase i think is is
is the
parent there so you used to go there so
why were they doing that they just
wanted foot traffic in the branch or
what
so here's the other thing is that
co-working
actually can actually be a great
customer
customer legion so another way is if you
want to go in the co-working business
it could actually be far more
interesting if you're a software i i
joked with my guys at hubspot i was like
guys we should do this
so if you're a software company i
actually think there's an interesting
play here to have a co-working
or if you're a bank something that you
are trying to get freelancers or
business owners and you have a super
high ltv of tens of thousands of dollars
it actually i think could be interesting
to do this yeah like i wonder
why doesn't uh you know every every tech
company spending so much money
recruiting engineers
um and like just recruiting in general
why not just have space as a recruiting
tool so
so you basically rent out space even if
you break even or are slightly
unprofitable you would make up for it in
the actual recruiting of people who are
there because they're in your orbit they
you know they're in the uber office in
the uber co-working ring
uh you know area and they get to eat the
food and whatever else
and sure enough you're just absorbing
talent uh you know as you go
as part of that i don't know if it'd be
worth it but it is uh
that's i don't know those are my
thoughts on co-working i don't have a
ton of thoughts i think that wework is
great
as a real estate company um and by great
i don't mean like
it's bulletproof obviously the pandemic
was sort of the worst possible thing
that could happen to any
co-working um you know co-working
company
but i i mean i do believe most most
value in real estate
is by uh change of use so you um you buy
a thing that's
valued at uh warehouse you know uh
square footage and you convert it into
self storage and you make more per
square foot
um that's what we work with doing it's
the same fundamental model as
uh self storage but they were doing it
with people
and uh and i think that that business if
not sort of managed by a lunatic
probably wouldn't have got as big as
fast but also would not have had the
fall it did
and um and i'm curious to see how this
shakes out i would be shocked like a lot
of people love to [__] on wework they
think it's a terrible business
well i would be shocked if 10 years from
now there wasn't
at least two or three multi-billion
dollar co-working uh companies out there
so like
you can [__] on the space you can share
it on wework but in reality i think that
there are gonna be winners in that space
let's talk about the the lunatic real
quick so you just said it was worn by a
lunatic if you're one of this is
probably even more fascinating so
i went and did a lot of research on this
and i talked to people
not this guy but other people who knew
adam or worked with adam yeah so wework
was run by this guy named madame newman
he was
like crazy maybe not always in a bad way
probably mostly in a good way
and i talked to a bunch of people and i
narrowed it down and i basically said
what makes this guy so great so
basically they are explaining to me
they're
they go adam was here's like a quote
from this woman i talked to adam
adam was unique on a one-to-one convo it
was like looking into it when i talked
to him it was like looking into a mirror
and seeing myself but that mirror was a
megaphone of my best self
he made me believe that i was the best
and i could do anything
and i asked him i was like was he's
dyslexic
isn't he and they go yeah i think he is
just
i've noticed that dyslexic people rank
so high on having this ability
to and this sounds negative and i don't
mean this negative to manipulate people
and to manipulate them into believing
that like
like to con to persuading and leading
people
and they and they just said he would i
would tell himself and he would echo it
back to me but for some reason i would
believe it and i believe that i was the
best that i possibly could be
and he made me feel that anything was
possible and i think that that is so
fascinating and even more
interesting than we work did you watch
the wework documentary on hulu
did you no i i did uh because you know
you get to sort of see firsthand what's
the guy like cause he's on camera it's
pretty raw
it's from you know it's footage from
when he when we work with sort of still
on the rise
and um and yeah it was sort of this cult
of personality around him he didn't seem
particularly
charming or anything like that but i
think
the thing i've seen with this is some
people are so irrational
in their belief right like it takes some
irrationality to do anything
because if if you're just perfectly
rational you look at your current
situation
and you'll say this is what it is and
anytime something else you know what
a goal or a vision or a dream it will
look completely irrational
and so we all have a little bit of
irrationality in us otherwise we
wouldn't have goals we wouldn't have
dreams
um he was like sort of 90 10 90
irrational maybe not even 10 rational
maybe it was just 99
1 uh irrational to rational where from
day one he was saying what this was
going to be
how amazing it was going to be how this
investor was going to give us
all every dollar that they had how this
customer was going to have the greatest
experience of their life
and he believed it with every bone in
his body and when you encounter somebody
with that kind of certainty
it is very like addictive and sort of
like intoxicating
um because if they believe in themselves
that much there's really two ways to go
some people become haters because they
don't have that sort of self belief in
themselves
and then other people sort of become
followers and they they join in because
they're just like being around that
level of certainty
so that was pretty cool i love it
by the way you know when i watched that
fire festival documentary yeah
i felt the same way i was like first of
all badass vision
fire special was a great idea with and
it almost worked
god-awful execution and it almost worked
it was so irrational that it almost
overcame rationality but it didn't it
failed in the end
but most people point and laugh and i
think that that was
you know like kind of an amazing swing
that was more impressive than that
failure was more impressive than most
people's successes
as far as i'm concerned i thought there
was a big big audacious vision got a
bunch of people on board
almost pulled it off um almost might be
a little generous but
uh you know at least what i mean is like
he rallied people around like almost in
the sense of like
it could have yeah sold all the tickets
got all the big names on board right
like
right you know and and it wasn't fraud
like it wasn't uh
intentional fraud from what i remember
like it wasn't like i think it was but
that's okay that that that's like not
entirely
important i mean i do think that like
there was fraud but like there was a
true belief of i can i can pull it off
right there's fake it till you make it
and then there's fraud fake it till you
make it is hey it's not there yet but
i believe i can pull this off we're
gonna do it we're gonna find a way if i
just tell them this
if i tell them it's already booked then
we'll figure out a way to get it booked
you know
intention matters i actually when we
hung out this weekend
i felt not the same thing but a little
bit
of that with you where you like you
didn't say these any audacious things
but you have this sense of belief it's
like well yeah why not
like you went and met with people that
i'm like really you're doing that yeah
just talk to him i'm gonna do this
like you do do you know that you have a
little bit of that in you
as well you you have a more of a i think
you
and this this is not insulting you are
because you're like emotionally healthy
you're not like adam to where you have
to say i'm gonna take over the world in
order to feel good
do you know what i mean yeah so like
you're very confident
you're you do [__] almost because you
just like it's more fun than it is out
of a
of a personality deficit of like i have
to be on top
and so it's a little bit more healthy
but you have that same
magnetism do you realize that right i do
realize it because i try to do that
and you know once you try it something
for like five years straight
you stop having to try you know effort
effort is what creates effortless
so i put an effort into it and now i
don't have to try that anymore it just
happens
and the reason why the reason i know i
did it was because i was very conscious
about it
the reason we both love conor mcgregor
and why i think really
any fan loves conor mcgregor is not
because of the way he throws his left
hand
when he punches it's because the guy had
this ludicrous self-belief
when he was literally on welfare you
know as a
as a failed plumber in ireland and he
was talking about how he's going to
become
you know the largest you know i'm going
to become a two-weight world champion
the biggest sports star on earth number
one on the forbes list
and then guess what this year where he
landed number one on the forbes list
he's the number one star in combat
sports
you know two-weight world champion
achieved and so
those of us who got to see that rise
it's yeah we're happy for connor but
really we're happy for ourselves that
holy [__] this guy with just literally
nothing but self-confidence
self-confidence drove him to work
because he believed that he could
achieve it
so he was motivated and then when he
worked plus the self-confidence
you know overcame all the odds and had
it maybe i can have some of that too put
a little bit of that in my drink
that's how i felt about it and so you
know i don't care about becoming a
two-weight world champion but
i have my own versions of those that i
just sort of decided why would i
why would i doubt myself right what's
that see what's you can see what's
written behind me this is my uh
this will be one of my sunday stories so
i don't want to i don't want to spoil it
but the the teaser is the teaser for
this sunday story time with sean is
doubt doubt if you're gonna doubt
anything doubt doubt
um and so that's how i feel now so how
do you feel confident uh well
you start to doubt doubt you you start
to lack lack
you start to doubt having lack you start
to lack having doubt that's that's where
you want to get to
in order to have that sort of unshakable
self-confidence what's that
conor mcgregor had that forbes saying
yeah the two-weight champion
uh what what what's yours uh i've always
said this i want to have a one percent
of the world's population
uh consider me someone who is you know
like they're one of their favorite
teachers somebody who who
who they've learned from so the version
of that that i saw was
that math teacher that guy beat you in
india who sold out a stadium he had a
stadium full of people come to watch him
teach
i thought that was incredible and you
know you start to see it into reality
right we just did a live show okay it
wasn't
it wasn't 70 million people it was 300
people it was 400 people showing up at
our live show
right but but you start to see that come
to come to fruition of like
okay a year ago that didn't exist that
who's to say a year from now that's not
3 000 people
who's to say you're from that it's not
30 000 people right like that seems
entirely believable to me and i've sort
of envisioned it and so when it happens
i won't be surprised i'll be pleased but
i won't be surprised
and i've actually heard stories about a
lot of these people so
um i've talked to a lot of the early
employees one of my good friends his
name's will he was like
number 40 or something at uber and he
tells me stories where he was like
uh he's like i just felt like anything
was possible it was i felt like i was in
in war and my co-workers were were my
fellow troops and i loved it i felt like
there was constant action
and we were in this together that had
this similar type of vibe i've heard
who else have you heard that from um i
mean hear from a lot of like fraudsters
obviously but yeah
who else it's the sword that cuts both
ways right
you know if you spot it you got it
that's that's sort of the way that most
of these things work
all the extreme strengths come with a
corresponding evil right just like
facebook a technology that connected
everybody in the world
and then guess what you know like
[__] chaos also from connecting
everybody in the world
the spread of information has never been
easier we can spread you know
and a student in india can you know has
more access to like knowledge than the
emperor
did you know 100 years ago well guess
what they also have access to fake news
and porn and all these other bad things
right like that's why it's funny
whenever somebody would criticize crypto
and say oh it could be used for all
these bad things
all that tells me is that this can be
used for extremely good things also
because there's a duality
with all of those and so that's how i
think about you know this extreme
confidence
if i was gonna rank i would put at the
top if you if you think about what's the
most intoxicating
desirable thing when you meet somebody
the first number one i would say
is a sense of peace when you meet
somebody who's truly happy
like they're not like bubbling over with
with joy
but they're just happy you know when
they're at rest when nothing is going on
or even when you know quote unquote bad
things are going on i think that is
when you see that it's really hard to
like you just want to be around that
person you want to be like that person
and who have you met anyone like that my
trainers like that like just the other
day
uh he came came to our house i think i
won
he trained me for 80-90 minutes then he
trained the next person and
trained next person so he was going from
1 p.m till 7 30 p.m
which doesn't sound like a lot of hours
but when you watch what he's doing like
he's not just sitting there like on his
phone while you're working out he's
fully on motivating you
changing the weights demonstrating the
thing bringing that excitement
talking to you whatever he's got to be
like switched on performing
and so it was like hour seven he hadn't
eaten anything he hadn't had a sip of
water
uh you know he hadn't had a single break
and it was just one person and it wasn't
even expected by the way it was just
somebody who was like at my house was
like oh can i get a session in
he's like come on in and so bye wait
wait wait wait wait you just had people
coming in to your house
like my mom was over and she she wanted
to work out normally she does it on a
different day but she he was like all
right yeah jump in i'm here
and so what happened was by the end of
it um
he so so i walk into the garage where he
where he was cleaning up the like kind
of like the workout stuff
and he's got this huge smile on his face
me and my wife we walked out because we
were gonna go for a walk
and uh we see him he's smiling he's
laughing i don't even know nobody was
there i don't know what he's smiling
about
he was just smiling and then he was
putting things away
and he just looks at me he goes part of
time and i don't even know what he was
talking about i have no idea what he was
thinking about but he just was like in
that mood
and he was this huge smile and i go man
i told my wife i go
man you know how i am at the end of a
work day like when i work hard
and i feel like i really exerted effort
and i had to go above and beyond and do
a little extra that day
i become like such a whiny little brat
like i'm like
i'm so tired i need to eat i need like
like i did so much now you know i know
you need to do that work i'm i'm done
you know
um and i become the sort of like
entitled little brat about
myself and you know and i'm like
crashing
and i felt like this guy was just like
i mean to come at me and be like party
time like i don't know what he was even
thinking about but that's not the way i
end my work day when i feel like i
worked overtime so what's number two
then you said happiness
the next one is the is the is the sort
of self-delusion it is the like
irrational confidence in self when you
meet somebody like that
that is intoxicating even if they are
not successful so like
i intentionally have not put rich and
famous people on this list yet because
i've had experiences with both you meet
a really successful person you meet a
really famous person
you meet somebody who is completely
happy or somebody who is
you know truly believes in themselves
even when you're like dude there's no
way you're gonna pull that off and they
truly believe it they're not just
boasting they're
puffing their chest out to me that is
like
you know that's a drug to be around
somebody like that because i want to be
like that
i want to be truly happy i want to be
truly confident and um and they they
don't even have to try to show it it's
just like
it's on their face it's in the way they
walk it's in the way they talk and um
and i can contrast that to the way i
think and i see oh that's the gap that's
where i want to be
so i think those are the two most i
guess like intoxicating things in people
what do you think is that the same for
you or is that just a method yeah and i
know a bunch of people like that and i'm
like
in both ways i'm like i'm exhausted i
can't be around you anymore but then i
crave it constantly and i
crave you when you're gone yeah yeah you
know what i mean like i've got like
when my friends talk about working with
travis so like are you gonna go work at
his new company they're like he's trying
to
recruit me and i just can't do i can't
go to war again but i'm just too worn
out but like
i miss it every day so it's like a it's
a duality there but yeah i completely
agree with you and i'm actually um
reading this book yeah the laws of human
nature
uh in order to like learn a little bit
more because i used to study this stuff
constantly i would read books on
influence and persuasion because i was
like
i can't build anything so i just have to
be a leader of
people and i've got to like persuade
people to do this because i
i can't do it i don't have the ability
so i i got to bring some attributes to
the table
and so that's my thing oh there you go
dan's reading it too
so what do you so like i read the laws
of human nature by robert greene which
is about like how to like influence
humans a little bit and how we think i
like
uh how to win friends that influence
people and i like think and grow rich
for self-confidence is there anything
you like
i don't know so book wise whatever maybe
i don't know but this you just reminded
me of something i read yesterday
there's a quora story about this guy who
interviewed at apple with steve jobs
have you ever read the story
no oh sorry i'm pulling it up right here
so you can uh
you can have the link but i was shaking
my head no yeah podcast bro we got to
have audio
um so um okay so so there's this thing
like
so this guy uh writes this anonymous
thing this might be by the way
this might just be straight up like fan
fiction so uh
so like if i fell for some fan fiction
you know my bad either way it was pretty
inspiring
this guy goes yeah i was at mit and um
uh you know i was getting recruited by
apple and i didn't want to work at apple
i wanted to go do something else i don't
know stay in school or like go to a
different job
he was like but you know people told me
like okay just go apple go go interview
see if you get the job see if you get an
offer like that's good for you so he
goes to apple
and he's uh he's sitting in the
interview and sure enough like they're
asking a bunch of questions that just
make him be like
if this is your question i just
definitely don't want to work here and
then he's like
then i heard this sort of like um sound
on the other side of the like kind of
the glass door or whatever the mirror
and uh and uh you know steve jobs walks
in
and uh steve jobs walks in and he kind
of like dismisses the vp who was like
doing the interview
and he looks he's like he sits down he
doesn't look at me he looks at the sheet
of questions
and he's just reading them he's like
like i don't know five six seven minutes
go by
he hasn't introduced himself he hasn't
said a word to me he hasn't looked up
and made eye contact
he is just reading this list of
interview questions
and he's like kind of scoffing at them
as he's reading them and he's just like
you know muttering kind of like like you
know stupid
uh and so he and he basically that you
know sort of the long story short is he
goes
um you know how would we ever expect
somebody interesting
to uh to work with us when we ask the
most uninteresting questions
and so he's like muttering that and so
he um he
he puts the paper down and he looks at
the guy and he goes
who are you and you go the guy kind of
like answers like most people would or
whatever he's like you know i'm tom
i don't know his name let's pretend he's
tom you know i'm tom uh
you know you know i'm interviewing for
the job here yeah i know what you're
doing i said who are you
who are you he's like uh you know
honestly i don't even really want this
job like you know like
i'm not that interested in working at
apple he's like he's i'm not asking if
you're interested in the job i'm asking
you who are right so he's like going
back and forth and the guy's like look
you know whatever
he tries to answer the question and then
steve's like why don't you want to work
at apple
and he goes uh honestly you know i just
blah blah steve goes
like take a walk with me right and steve
jobs famous for like these walking
meetings
so he he's like okay like i guess so you
know
and he said he takes a walk with him and
so they they walk around the
sort of campus and he's like you can
literally see like it's like he's got a
like a gravity field around him like
everywhere he walks people just clear
the path
uh because they don't want to like talk
to him they don't want to like get in
his way bother him or anything like that
he's like we're talking and he's giving
me the whole spiel like
you know we're making some really great
stuff here like we're
really really great like you won't
believe er just like kind of the like
steve in the keynote he's doing the the
kind of like build up
he's not telling him anything yet uh but
he's telling him it's really great
he's like you got to meet john johnny
ive right you can be johnny
and they go into johnny ive's office and
he's showing him cool stuff or whatever
anyways the story ends with with the guy
sort of like
getting wrapped up in the like
intoxication of steve jobs
he's like dude i told you i don't want
to work here i don't want to work here
and steve jobs is like um give me a
month
it'll be the best month of your life um
uh i will
you know i'll pay you three times what
your normal rate would be for the month
you know for one month i'll make you pay
you triple we'll get you a car or an
apartment or whatever else
um just say yes and like say yes and
we're it's done the guy's like
okay and he's like fantastic and he's
like jennifer uh jennifer will help you
from here
and like jennifer yeah you know like
whatever he like goes and introduces
or he he leaves the guy for a second
he's like okay jennifer's gonna help you
jennifer now knows all the details about
this whole situation asks no questions
um you know has him sign a thing he's
like what's my job title it's like
you're a steve hire he's like who do i
report to
i guess you'll report to steve we don't
know uh don't ask those questions those
are not
questions you want to ask steve and is
like um okay cool but like
uh i don't live here i live in
pittsburgh so i gotta like move my stuff
like um or no no he's like he's like you
know i i just have kind of my suitcase
with me they're like no no steve's
arranging all of your stuff to be moved
here
he's like well i don't know if i'm gonna
stay the month he's like that's okay
we'll move it back if you decide not to
steve prefers
he wants you to have your stuff here and
your apartment is across the street
here's your keys
and a car will be there waiting for you
and he's like this was like an hour of
total time had elapsed and somehow like
the world had moved
to make steve's like wish come true and
so
i don't know again this might just be
fair do you think this might just be fan
fiction
and even if it is i [__] love it it's
a great like you know random ass
tech fan fiction god i love that but if
it's true how [__] cool is that
i i i find it hard to believe it's so
cool
and also there's no [__] point to the
story right like
i read the story i was like what's the
point of this story i didn't know
it stuck in my head and i told you now
and you know
tens of thousands of listeners and i
still don't know what the point of the
story is excited from
how [__] cool is that if that
happened i think it's sick and i've
and and and to bring it back to like
these personality things
um culture to wrap it up any
i mean you've got a good personality uh
what do you any resources
for like improving that i'll tell you
one thing i do i think that the whole
cult of personality ego thing
that might work for some people where
they're like i'm great this place is
great we're gonna do great work i think
that works
i find that to be really hard in
practice to like
uh execute with a straight face and so
the thing that i use as like maybe my
stepping stone towards being more like
that
is i i do this exercise with anybody i
work with um
and in fact you know we met dan in miami
this was the one dan wanted to chat
about ideas for the podcast because he's
trying to do his job he's like
hey i have a bunch of ideas for how we
can grow the pod and make it work better
and we did that normally what i would do
when i first bring anyone onto the team
is i basically do like a dream exercise
with them i'm like okay come to this off
come to the come to the whiteboard room
we go to the whiteboard and they expect
me to like kind of outline their role or
talk about the project i'm like no no
like
same sort of thing who are you who
you're trying to be by the time you're
done here
this this job this job is like getting
into a car
right you're gonna have a bunch of it's
going on a road trip you're gonna have a
bunch of other people in the car with
you
we you know we're cool it's gonna be a
fun hang the music is good the vibe is
nice
roll up the window you're gonna feel it
feel the air going through you know
through your hair
okay we're trying to get to some
destination and your job is not to be
like focused on the car
making the car as great as it can be
you're recognize that every business
every
experience is just a vehicle to get you
to some other
like destination for yourself and so
like what is that for you
who are you today and who do you want to
walk out of here as and i start getting
them pumped talking about themselves
and um usually people have a very hard
time even having a vision for themselves
right it's like
it's normal to have a vision for the
company and a mission for the company
9 out of 10 people maybe 99 out of 100
people don't have a vision for
themselves or a mission for themselves
right and uh and how crazy is that like
yourself is a lot more important than
than the
the corporation you work for and so i
try to like sketch
that with them and that does two things
one is
um they realize that i care about them
as a person
uh and i'm here to like i'm gonna help
them get where they wanna go
right and then the second thing is i get
to see how they're wired i get to see
what makes them tick i get to see what
they're motivated by so now
when it comes time to get great you know
great effort out of them i know what
moves the needle for them personally
um so that's the thing that's a thing i
do that's like kind of in this realm
i i i feel like i'm taking notes
i dig this [__] do you want to um
just bang out a few quick ideas you want
to start with you want to do let's do
the top barrels
let's do can i tell the story about
hyper ice and then we'll talk about the
ice barrels
go for it had you heard about hyper ice
before do you know this
what is it so it's this thing you might
have seen
if you've ever seen anybody who's an
athlete and um after they work out or
whatever they're wearing they're not
like going in an ice tub anymore
they're wearing this black thing that's
wrapped around their legs that like is
pumping some air or
compression or cooling into their like
onto their body
yeah um you know the first time you see
it they it looks weird right they're
like kind of like
it's like they're the michelin man they
have did you discover this from the guy
who tweeted at us
no who tweeted ass oh someone was like i
want to send you guys hyper eye stuff
oh no way uh maybe he listens to the pod
that would be amazing
but uh i don't know i just saw this
because
um a random random story but like
i saw it because in the nba games now
you always see nba players all of a
sudden for the first time ever
when they go to the bench to rest they
don't just sit there and rest right like
it used to be you go
sit down and rest the camera doesn't
even show you then the camera starts
showing you because they want to show
your facial reaction
and then what happened in the jordan era
was he's always drinking gatorade right
he's a sponsored athlete
gatorade gatorade gatorade inside the
cup of gatorade is probably water
but like he's holding a gatorade cup
always right because gatorade wanted to
be
the way you refuel your body you know as
a drink right they wanted that
that that niche and by partnering with
all the sports team it was sort of a
genius thing right
uh when the super bowl ends they dumped
the gatorade on the coach right they
created these
uh branding moments and so now every
year at the super bowl hundreds of
millions of people see the gatorades
uh you know canister how genius is that
so
i saw a new thing that caught my
attention
and it was lebron went to the bench and
he took this ferragun looking thing out
he started you know like self-massaging
using this gun on his leg to like
recover while he was resting and i was
like oh that's cool and it wasn't a
theragan it was like a different device
so i went looked it up
as thing called hypervolt and hypervolt
is made by hyper ice
so what is this company so it's the same
company that makes those those cooling
like uh straps or i don't know what you
would call it like this giant black
thing you
put it's a sleeve you put on your leg
around your leg and it's like a way to
ice your legs after you work out
and so here's the back story there's a
guy who's like a teacher and a high
school basketball coach
and um he was you know sort of
always he was just a coach and he was
sort of thinking about recovery because
you know you get into your 30s and now
when you're
after you work out or after you play
basketball you're gonna like not be able
to walk great the next day
and uh so he was sort of experimenting
like is there anything better than just
icing
like basically he thought to himself
what do the pro athletes do he's like
they ice they ice their knees they ice
their ankles
and if you watch them do it it always
looked the same it was like a giant bag
of ice
yeah with an ace bandage around the top
of it and it literally
looks like a wounded person right like
you look like you're hurt
if somebody was to draw a cartoon of
somebody with a bum shoulder they would
draw this giant ice bag on the top
and um and you know and and basically
uh bandage wrapped around it so he's
like that sucks like
you're not like broken uh you're
recovering could we make recovery
look cool and be more efficient so he
starts trying to design
a ice wrap that's less inconvenient and
looks cooler
so he's like oh it'd be cool if it just
like you just strapped on to you and it
wasn't a bag of ice that was like
you know getting wet everywhere if it
was just cold and um you know so he
starts working on it and his friend
is a guy who trains with kobe or he's
like a
the coach of a little college that kobe
used to train at uh irvine
in the summers and so his friend sees
his thing and goes
dude you've got to show this to kobe and
he's like oh okay yeah sure
and he's like you know a week later he's
like dude i told kobe kobe was icing his
knees after
after we did a workout and i told him
about your thing he wants to see it can
you come
so he goes he shows kobe and kobe says
two things he's like
first you know some product feedback
like when we're icing
uh you know the pressure keeps escaping
out of the top so like it's not working
it's not compressing tight enough so can
you fix that
the guy's like got his notepad out he's
like yeah yeah for sure and kobe's like
also um the name [__] sucks he's like
oh uh okay
uh hyper ice you know actually i named
it after you your favorite chew and my
favorite shoe is like the hyperdunks
uh by nike so i thought hyper ice and
kobe's like name sucks
and uh but he ended up keeping it and so
he ended up doing product development
with kobe
and kobe made him a deal with kobe goes
look if you can make it better than my
current thing i'll wear it on the bench
so you'll get free kind of exposure you
know from this thing you see these
pictures of kobe with icing his shoulder
using hyper ice
so kobe does it people see it on the
bench more athletes started asking more
lakers start asking for it now other
teams players start asking for it he
builds a brand around this
and what he's building is nike for
recovery
so which is like the greatest that i
mean that's wonderful that's wonderful
because that um calm he says that he
wants to be the nike for
meditation or nightmare for the mind
yeah and
that makes sense i get that i think
that's cool i think this is even better
it's even better exactly because what is
nike nike was all about the performance
when you're on the court when you're on
the field wear this you can run faster
jump higher blah blah
and then that became a super competitive
space how do we get you to perform
better
right wear this wear this under armor
you know um you know use these cleats
whatever it is
um but nobody was really he's like you
would see them wear
all this gear sell billions of dollars
of merchandise by wearing it on the
court
and then when they got off the court
they were using ace bandages and plastic
bags of ice
what is a brilliant um insight brilliant
right [__] he's like dude i had no
idea
no intention to go into business i was a
happy teacher and coach but like you
know i just sort of stumbled on this
path really
and so now hyper ice they do they have
the ice
product they have the theragun type
product i'm looking at it and and i like
this company because
their shit's expensive and i would
consider we're going to talk about
another thing that's expensive i would
consider buying this because
i think expensive good health equals
good
yeah like when i see that and it like
loves music equals good
expensive equals good right yeah like
everything i their branding is tight
it's a well executed thing so let me
give you some numbers last year 100
million in revenue is what they said
they were projecting 200 million this
year
it raised last year at a 700 million
valuation so it's gonna be
you know if this continues to work this
will be a billion dollar plus company
that was started
in the way that i just described how
[__] cool is that story i love that
story
and i love this concept we have an idea
you have an idea and i have a couple
other ideas about what else you can do
here but
here's the framework the framework is
athletes are the one of the greatest
marketing vehicles of all time go look
at the shoe companies if you want proof
of that
uh go look at gatorade go look at who
mcdonald's and coke will sponsor it's
the top athletes
even though they're obviously not eating
mcdonald's and drinking coke in order to
perform their best but that's that's
they're the best marketing vehicle
and the native placement is what matters
so it's one thing to say
you know i'm holding a coke and or you
know mcdonald's
in a commercial it's another thing to
watch them actually drinking
you know from a gatorade cup during the
thing or wearing hyper ice after they
train
because that's feels real it feels like
this is what the pros this is what top
performers actually do
so looking at the pregame and the post
game
how much more is there if you walked
into a locker room before and after a
game
what are all the other things you'll see
them doing and then how could you turn
those
from unbranded moments into branded
moments right
beats by dre is a perfect example of
this beats by dre
sold to apple for three billion dollars
one of the reasons why is
they made headphones well all right
there's already a bunch of headphones
out there there's sonos there's
sennheiser there's all these other ones
and um what beats by dre did was they
gave it to all the athletes that they
you know drew was had the
kind of hip-hop roots and then all their
commercials if you remember was
colin kaepernick showing up to the game
the fans are booing him he puts the
beats by dre on he goes into the zone
he can't hear the noise all he hears is
his music and then he goes to the game
right
they intentionally always put it in the
lockers of all the players so when
they're doing their interviews
they have headphones around their neck
they have headphones hanging right
behind them
right they're walking into the arena
that has become like
before every nba game you they show the
walk-in what is lebron wearing
uh when he walks in so those become
branded moments where maybe you can
build products around that
and he obviously got all the right
people to invest i'm looking at the
crunch base it's all athletes fernando
tatis
ricky fowler doc rivers deandre jordan
uh
what's that one uh naomi osaka osaka
yeah
uh this guy's gonna crush it this is the
greatest thing ever
and so tell me about this ice barrel
thing because i think you have a cool
story around this
uh so i was at a friend's house i've
talked about him he lives a few doors
down from me
and his name's andy and he started this
company called student loan here i
believe and he sold it for a lot of
money 60 million bucks and i was at his
house for
lunch my wife and i and he had this huge
barrel and i was like what the [__] is
this thing
he goes it says company that i just
bought a large stake in and i'm helping
them get their [__] right
and it's this barrel that you hop into
and it's just an ice barrel that's all
it is is a nice barrel
but there's one pretty shocking thing
about it it's two thousand dollars so
like i'm in this text group with you
well set this up in in the way that that
you're you're you're an athlete
right people saw the quads they saw
quadzilla in the in the twitter
funny that picture right they
saw the quads uh you were a track jack
athlete
when you were done training did you ever
ice yeah did you do ice baths
yes and what did you do for in your post
game if i had walked in the locker room
looking for startup ideas what would i
have seen you doing
oh i mean you're just sitting in the ice
bath you're just sitting there the ice
bath made of it's not a barrel
well they use like trash cans typically
like literally
like you'll use like a shitty trash can
or you'll use these
massive plastic buckets but typically
like a trash can
right so it's this unbranded thing that
the athletes are doing to recover
and it's like this literally like a 64
gallon
black trash can which is kind of gross
of an idea that that's
what do i do to recover i get in a
[__] trash can right so like
that was the opportunity to make that
sexy and cool in a branded moment
and that's what these guys did it's a
giant cool looking like
barrel so you know it's like like a like
where you would store like whiskey or
something like that and there's actually
a few reasons why i think this is going
to be big so
the best example i could think of is
yeti there's two examples yeti and
weather tech
weather tech makes floor mats boring
silly thing
i buy whenever i buy a car i immediately
buy weather tech maps
yeah right away and they like you think
that these are like kind of forgotten
things same with yeti yeti was just
you know everyone has a coleman cooler
growing up they just made it cool
and they like are 4x more expensive than
the nearest competitor
and yet we all do it and this what's it
called ice barrel.
basically if i was going to distill
their formula it's like
double the value quadruple the price
right like
that's the way i would i would like
describe it plastic thing but the reason
why it's cool is those trash cans
if you're like a a big guy like i kind
of am like you can't like
push down on the thing otherwise it's
going to like collapse
yes and so you gotta like getting that
sucks and it's and it's inconvenient
it's not that inconvenient but it's
inconvenient
but for the type of person that ice
baths like if you're gonna like
make it a little bit more convenient and
it's two grand i'm like [__] it whatever
i don't care
like like five hundred dollars and two
thousand 000 is like kind of like the
same thing to me a little bit when it
comes to like health
and fitness right so i'll buy it if i if
i'm into that
and so it doesn't really look that
spectacular but when your shit's two
grand
you don't need to sell that many of them
i mean if you're selling
40 a day what's that 40 a day is 80k a
day in revenue
times 30 uh that's uh
2.4 million dollars a month which is 36
million dollars a year
you got to sell very little and that's
kind of why i like this business
i think and and i think i talked to him
about it i i he says it costs a lot of
money
uh because it they it costs them a lot
of money right so like it's
a pretty interesting business are you
bullish on that i love that idea i
wouldn't have been as bullish until i
looked at it through this through this
lens now i see now i see the value
the other ideas that i think are like
this so if i was gonna be like okay what
else what else can i do
um we've talked before about saunas i
think saunas
are going to agree saunders are just
going to keep exploding in popularity
100 agree joe rogan is kind of like the
lebron in this case who's been touting
them but
a lot of athletes use saunas i had one
kind of like i had to keep one on amazon
for a grand it was called the barcelona
yes exactly so uh i want you know like
where is our spanish sponsorship i'm
waiting for my home sauna sponsorship
uh you know i think a lot of people are
gonna install home saunas there's also
like
other like technologies like that like i
forgot like red
red light therapy and some other [__]
like that i don't know what they are but
i like to always educate me and then
sell me right that's what you got to do
if you're
i tried buying a um sensory deprivation
tank
so i used to go to this place in the
mission in san francisco and i'd pay 50
and you like sit in this thing that kind
of looks like a tanning bed and it's
filled with water and salt and you just
float for
uh like an hour and it was quite nice i
loved it
i tried to buy one i was like sure i was
like you know i've got space what i'll
put one in my garage how much is it
it's like 20 000 or i mean it's like a
[__] ton and it doesn't have to cost
that much money so so here's the why
why is it i don't need a full body tank
that works but
if somebody made a dope helmet that was
like
go to the place of silence it's like
what you go in this thing and you're not
gonna hear a [__] thing or you're
gonna hear
specific sounds like you know like
calming sounds whatever it is
um i think somebody could sell a helmet
that is gonna like
basically change your state sort of like
the sensory deprivation idea
um as just a helmet i think that would
be kind of cool as a random idea
all right ice barrel what else so we got
sauna we got ice barrel we got sensory
deprivation here's another one
i bought these little things uh so man i
could go pick them up but they're
basically these little
inflatable um pods so it's like a little
inflatable
uh plastic thing that i saw lebron using
so lebron has his like warm-ups
that's become part of the television
programming as they show lebron before
the game what is he doing to get ready
and i saw he was always standing on or
kneeling on
these two little clear plastic things
and one time when he was recovering from
injury the reporter kind of showed
lebron's been using this thing
it's this instability ball and the idea
is like a bosu ball
basically you when you stand on it it
gives you an uneven un like uneven
surface right because most of our weight
training we are on flat
you know hard stable surfaces but then
when you do athletic things you're not
always landing at the exact yeah
as that so he does his training on top
of that he does all his warm-ups there
and it like warm ups all his sort of
like
little micro muscles and microfibers
they all get activated when he just
spends time squatting on this hand
standing on this balancing on this
same thing with steph curry for his
ankles he does the same thing
and so i think that little products like
that can work
uh ben sent me another one of these
that's like a medicine ball that's
filled with water
so you take a traditional piece of
equipment like a medicine ball
it's just hot it's just you know solid
and heavy when you put water in it and
you move it from side to side the water
you know your arms move and then the
water sloshes in that direction
and then if you're trying to move back
the water is moving one way you're
moving the other so it's a good
resistance training
and so i think water-based uh
water-based training things if the
athletes are doing that i think that's
kind of interesting and people want to
buy what the athletes buy
the other is braces knee braces ankle
braces shoulder wraps
wrist wraps you know like anything that
is
um like injury prevention i think could
be sexed up because they are usually
uh pretty like basic stuff right now
there's a when you're talking i'll keep
googling but there's a
so you know how when you get surgery you
uh have your head like
you've never had this but you know like
if you've ever seen your parents or
friends get like a
shoulder surgery you have to keep your
shoulder in this like particular type of
cast where your arm stays up high
the l yes so there's this brand that
is a startup that is like remaking those
and
it's called like what was it called it's
like champion sports or something
where they did a whole thing around
these soft casts so like when you have
like a walking boot
they made like cool walking boots and
that's actually a great one it's like a
cooler walking boot
and they built this business all around
this and that's actually really
interesting as well
there was a woman who uh i don't
remember the name of it but i'll try to
find it
maybe we'll put it in the show notes
there's a woman who uh was like a
designer of some kind and she got like
paralyzed and went in a wheelchair and
then she like changed her life mission
she designed herself like the coolest
looking wheelchair that didn't look like
you know you're you know if you're
younger like how do you make a
wheelchair look slick
it had like cup holders a place for your
phone it was just like nice looking it
wasn't the kind of like blue and metal
like kind of look that you see at a
hospital and she just made like an
awesome looking wheelchair and it's like
hey look if you're in a wheelchair
um like okay but let's make it as good
as we can
and she was like this is my new life
mission i thought that was pretty great
too by the way it's called
game ready check it out go to
gameready.com it looks like they're
acquired um they were doing 35 million
dollars a year when they got acquired
this is the ice thing yeah wow it only
got
acquired for 65 million dollars but yeah
go to game ready they it's
they have ice stuff but they also have
like post surgery equipment
uh kind of interesting right yeah same
ways i think that
i think there's an opportunity the
brainstorm would be
go hang out with an athlete follow them
pre-game post game
during the game during timeouts and just
look for what are all the things that
everybody's doing that's unbranded
and then can you make a higher quality
branded version of this can you create
um you know can you and then you use
that marketing strategy of the trickle
down you give the athletes the coolest
[__]
other people see it and you sell it to
the wannabe athletes you're not making
the money from the athletes themselves
you're
making the money off of right like ice
barrel what they need is
they need they need you to see this in
pro locker rooms
and then he then they need every high
school to be like oh that's what
you know that's what the lakers used
when they're recovering or that's what
the
you know the um the patriots use in
their locker room dude i feel like
um i i gotta email this guy and be like
hey we'll just give you a shout out
we're definitely gonna get this guy's
sales it's a small company i don't think
they i think it's only like two
employees
they're definitely gonna see a bump from
this and we're gonna have to ask them
how many people bought because
iceberry.com uh
just go there right now and buy their
[__] and actually by the way it's not
two grand i got it wrong it's uh
1200 yes 1200 uh yeah they're like
thanks for the shout out [__] you uh
you made it seem
even more expensive than it is yeah i
thought it was two grand
it's 1200 maybe the big one is 2 000
anyway
it's cool it's a cool thing i'm excited
to actually see how this works their
their website looks pretty slick what is
this
i don't know this looks great so those
are some ideas
uh yeah i think that might be it peace
out
we actually have like way more but we're
going to save those for later
yeah dan what'd you think yeah so i like
the episode
i like the co-working section i think
you guys bring a unique perspective to
that
and having worked and we work it's
exciting to know that there are some
i guess new opportunities and that whole
concept isn't going to die
uh with wework what was it what was the
absolute best part of the episode
the best part of the episode
i like the recovery stuff i have one of
the
the knockoff um like uh hypervolts or
whatever i like using that i haven't
done
a uh an ice barrel before but i have
some friends that have done like those
like cold chambers or whatever you do
like the two minutes inside
yeah you know what else blows that up by
the way wim hof wim hof has
gotten really popular in like you know
some knee circles i guess but
uh he's all about cold cold submerging
yourself and cold would you pay 3500
to go to his house and train with him
wim hof
you can do it maybe i i s it's something
like two or three or four thousand
dollars i think i would do that it's not
the money
it's more the time like yeah if i had a
little bit of time yeah i would love to
do that that'd be great
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back